listo la clase de hoy va a ser bastante corta pero lo que les voy a enseñar van a aplicarlo a todo
ya o sea con lo que voy a hacer les voy a enseñar van a poder ya casi implementar toda la automatización
las demás clases ya van a ser más como les explico de automatización pero más de que ya no
depende de nosotros mucho y que yo todo se vaya recepcionando automáticamente ya hacer agencia
citas envía ya diferentes tipos de aspectos tecnológicos a sus clientes y viceversa eso
ya se va a poder hacer así que con lo que diagamos ya se finaliza casi muchos puntos también
comentarles no lo siguiente que si van a utilizar sus números telefónicos solo solo hagan para
prueba ya que va a funcionar normal con sus números propios pero mejor si lo hacen con
whatsapp business yo para que tengan un mejor flujo y si quieren hacer pruebas masivas yo les
recomiendo con whatsapp business ya para pruebas masivas en su personal no les conviene porque pueden
vanearles así pero como se lo explicó de la clase pueden vanearles a partir de 500 600
mensajes día ahí sí ahí sí los pueden vanear porque van a pensar que es marketing ya pero como
les había comentado todo esto normal normal para un negocio mediano pequeño da es que no ya ya se
puede comprarse que van a tener afluencia de de clients más allá de los mil usuarios no
ellos pueden adquirir una un plan de pagos ahora si empezaremos chico
y ahora si empezaremos la hoy día la clase es casi finalizando ya la demacia
de estética mejoras y demás que pasó
como está el profe como le comenté estaba un poquito
retrasado en algunas grases ya me estoy casi poniendo al día para lanzar y no sé si es posible que me
pueda enviar el api de dipstick o para que ya continuo listo ahorita ahorita lo envío
dipstick listo y a vayan y ni se me dice no se me en 8 n vayan implementando eso y vayan activando su
docker ya en 8 n y docker vayan a tibandolo levantándolo ya listo y ahorita voy a enviar
mientras tanto mientras lo envío voy a habilitar también docker ya docker desktop y entre no y y
dirá listo ya y vamos a esperar para tardar unos 10 minutos a lo mucho ya ve que otra
otra cuenta de dipstick
listo
ahora si mientras tanto mientras va habilitar anduin más vamos a ver cómo va a ser nuestro
flujo posterior ya bueno veo que va a tardar bastante así que
del anterior de weaver
a ver voy a entrar en mi cuenta
que raro pero ahora te lo sé si lo subió el vídeo dice su compañero
ya mientras tanto
mil discrubs me mientras también bien lento así que tarde incluso no abrir a los cosas
ya mientras estoy esperando
voy a mal listo dentro unos 10 minutos ya para
eso va a ser nuestro
y
bueno yo se levantó mi dipstick y para mi docker voy a ver mientras tanto si he subido la grabación
creo que he subido
a ver
e
wanted啊
cev pes刻
Ya, si lo subido te comento, está acá, el compañero que me acaba de preguntar está
acá, dice que lo hace número 14, 18 de home, ya ahí está, listo, ahora si, voy a habilitar
mis asistencias y hasta que me habilite el N8N normalmente vamos a poder trabajar ya de
un ratito, activo el excel, donde estaban ustedes ahora, ya aprovechando voy a ver mi localhost
y ahora si
ya me he sabido habilitar, no seguí, voy a ver el chico de sus asistencias, ya me lo listo y con eso ya
no hay problema, hoja 3 o 4, voy a tratar de llamar listas siempre 10 minutos después de
iniciar la clase, ya que lo que no voy a llamar más listas, como éstamos en las últimas para que
también sea justo para los que asisten más que todo, ya, así que en eso es eso vamos a empezar,
ya mientras con eso he habilitado casi voy hasta llamando lista ya,
así que están en el entro,
ahora si,
suelamos 2 minutos más, ya no voy a volver a llamar lista y ahora si apretaremos o ya empezaremos,
ya ahí lo tienen, ya cuando ya lo han levantado entonces tanto suen hecho en como lo han levantado
su docker, ya podemos trabajar, ya esta parte no se preocupen, siempre tarda en la media de los casos,
ahora para levantar esto van a ser lo siguiente, aquí se dan cuenta esta cosita, ya hay post de
la IPA, lo que tenían que instalar si o si, ahora en la parte de acá dice lo cargo 777, eso pueden
tratar de clicarlo, si cliquen esto les voy a habilitar directamente la interfaz y levantada,
o sea fíjense me ha votado acá, ya ahí está, vuelvas a repetir, tiene que estar si o si aquí
en estos botones cuadrados, eso significa que está ahí levantado, este no, está apagado por ejemplo,
ya yo les recomiendo si es que van a utilizar lo que se, consecuentemente déjenlo así por defecto,
ya pues ya no lo van a utilizar y demás, si quieren mantener ahí luego van a continuar
proyectos, lo van a tratar de clicar, porque, porque en la media de los casos uno puede gastar
un poco de su RAM, de su memoria RAM y dos en este caso, solo algunas latencias, la comp,
que me refiero con latencias que siempre disminuen la velocidad un poquito de sus de
esos procesos que manejan, así que si es que no lo van a utilizar, déjenlo ahí, si es que lo van a
utilizar consecuentemente déjenlo prendido todo el tiempo, no hay problema, ya, entonces una vez
que tengan eso voy a volver a clicar acá, dos veces y se va a habilitar la ventanita, ya se me
habilitaba a mil, se va a habilitar una ventana en Chrome o en cualquier navegador que se está
realizando, ya, y las tiene que aparecer tal cual, y ahora esta parte se copia donde se ha hecho
TTP, control C, control B y listo entran y directo les va a votar esto, ya por ejemplo,
ya tengo ahorita que mi Qubit, lo voy a borrar con esto, ya lo voy a borrar, porque voy a hacerlo
con ustedes, esperamos un rato, listo, ahora lo borra, ya, ya, esto y usted dice que no se puede
borrar, esto sabe tardar ahí, veces dos días, tres días en eliminarse, si quieren eliminar de la
manera directa pueden ir a su soporte, pero hoy va a tardar, así que mejor si lo trabajan de manera
normal, ya, si no utilizan un número siempre desactivenlo, no les sugiero que lo activen, porque igual
puedo que hacen los problemas a futuro si están activados y no utilizan, ya, haremos, bueno todo
esto ustedes ya lo tienen, ya ya lo tienen ustedes, entonces lo que voy a hacer es instanciarlo,
ya vamos a instanciarlo, ya les explico esta parte, acá generalmente van a colocar ustedes el nombre
si es mejor repiten el mismo número de su teléfono acá, pero yo voy a tratar de hacerlo con algún
tipo de sincronía, es decir mi empresa, mi empresa número dos, ya, o empresa dos voy a colocarlo,
no lo que han tan complicado, pero siempre manejen numeritos, porque hay veces se va a desconfibrar
si no manejamos de manera ordenada, segundo punto, tienen que utilizar o bien Evolution o bien Bailey,
Bailey es lo más fácil de utilizar o más rápido, así que Bailey va a utilizar, las va a dar un
token adjunto y las va a dar el número, este número es de su empresa, ya, siempre tienen que
colocar en base a qué, en base al número de código de país, ahora voy a hacer con el mío,
ya no me acuerdo, el número de mi empresa y vamos a hacer el, acá es la misma que estoy viendo
ahí, pero damos ratito chicos, ustedes igual vayan, vayan notándose ahí sus, sus nombres,
sus nombres y demás, ya de sus empresas, yo voy a habilitar la de que hubiera la mente para ver
qué tal, dame un ratito, siempre van a tener hasta tres números para así van a ser altos negocios
automáticos, siempre es bueno, ya, así que demos ratito, no me acuerdo mi número, creo que
se es el mismo que estaba colocándolo, ya, mi número es 766-58749, está bien, ya, lo colocan esto y lo
guardan, ya, ahí está la empresa dos, hay que esperar un poco y demás, ya, ahora se van a entrar acá
y aquí les voy a hacer todo este aspecto más, un poquito
aplicativo, ya, incluso voy a notarme uno más de un ratito, vamos a seguirnos acá y voy a notarme
instancia genérica, voy a colocar empresa tres para hacer algunas pruebas igual,
mi personal, veil y guarte, 191-732-086, listo, lo guardamos, ya está,
ahí pueden crearse varias empresas, ustedes no hay problema, ya, una vez que tengan todo eso,
ya vamos a empezar, escaneal, voy a empezar con mi empresa número, van a venir acá, hace un clic
y aquí dice get query code, ya, ese get query code, van a ser la siguiente manera,
perdón, voy a ver si está grabando, será clase, van a ser la siguiente manera,
ehh, entranzas a su whatsapp business o a su whatsapp normal, ustedes
y van a escanearlo, ya, seguramente hay una, cuando ustedes van se bloquean con la URL de algún tipo de,
por ejemplo su whatsapp para su computadora, tienen que hacer la vinculación, no, es el
es el Héctor de Corea Ganó, van a tres puntitos de su whatsapp, van a colocar, hay unas opciones que
dicen, a ver a quinta opción dice dispositivos vinculados, ahí hacen clic y ahí dice,
voy a borrar un vinculación, es solamente les permite hacer cuatro, ya, whatsapp así que voy a
quitar algo, si quieren comprar más vinculaciones pueden hacer, pero voy a colocar vincular
dispositivo, ya, y cuando ya estén listos van a generar esto,
esperan un rato y eso lo van a escanear, obviamente a ustedes, no el mío, si no se van a escanear
con el mío y, y les va a dar error, ya, así que entrense con sus determinadas cosas,
con tres años y listo, ya, yo me voy a vincular y ya está, ya me vinculado yo a mi propio número,
va a tardar, desiniciando su seo, ustedes hagan lo mismo con sus propios n8n,
ya, ahí tienen que estar, no tienen que soltarlo y tienen que estar ahí bien,
listo y hasta lo voy a cerrar y hasta vinculado, ya, aquí dice conectado y en su celular les
va a aparecer nombre del dispositivo, ahí van a colocar, no sé Juan Ventas me dice a mi por defecto,
voy a colocar, no sé, Milton Ventas, Milton Ventas o Milton, no se va a colocar, mejor si es la misma
empresa de ustedes, de mi se llama QBit, voy a colocar QBit Ventas, listo, ya lo he guardado,
como ya lo he guardado, lo siguiente que tenemos que hacer es procesarlo, ya, una vez que escanemos
el código, vamos a ingresar a los settings, ya, ahora si nos vamos acá al dashboard, hay algunas
documentaciones y configuraciones, ya, por ejemplo, yo voy a ingresar directamente a mis settings,
voy a venirme acá a configuraciones, voy a irme a mis settings, algo clica en settings
y ahí, lo siguiente, esta parte por ejemplo, nosotros lo vemos más, o sea, si ustedes están
trabajando con business, qué es lo que no quieren ver, por ejemplo, en mi caso yo no quiero ver
estados de las personas, no me interesa porque es más negocio de mí, mejor que lo que vean mis
estados, pero yo no quiero ver estados, es luego, en este caso, por ejemplo, si a mí por error me
agregan a un grupo, a mi whatsapp business, sabemos que hay veces cuando alguien me escribe
automáticamente, se responde con mensajes automáticos, imagínense que me agregan en un
grupo y me mensaje todo el grupo, va a ocasionar un montón de cosas, o sea, al grupo le vamos a enviar
nuestras ventas y van a quedar ustedes expuestos, así que eso también elimina. Por ejemplo, a mí
justamente a su ratito me acaba de pasar un accidente, en qué sentido, por ejemplo, tengo una
comunidad donde hace dos días, tres días he hecho un tiktok y demás y se han empezado a
donar pues un montón de personas, casi 100 o 200 personas, pero qué ha pasado, casi un cuarto de
esas personas eran bots que te ofrecen, que se llama bitcoins y demás. Ahora, se se ha dado
cuenta lo que está pasando últimamente cuando te van enviando bitcoins, que respiran mirales,
etcétera, automáticamente ya no te mandan un mensaje para vanearte, te mandan n mensajes,
las personas que quieren hacer o fregar tu retigams, ya tienes qué pasa, el único
forma de evitar eso es eliminándolo a la persona, pero saben que ustedes se pueden
linkar por otras cuentas, los que generalmente hacen sus estafas piramidas, es que o bien tienes
las opciones, o bien contratas o creas tu propias búsqueda o tu destrucción para ellos, o pero
su tarde un poco, o bien directamente muteas a todos y lamentablemente solamente tú ya tienes
que enviar en un novia no puede dar y un reposter ir más lo más conveniente, esto pasa lo mismo,
te pueden enviar a vos bots y vos mismo auto enviarte y fregar el sistema, pues es que esto es mejor
cerrar los dos puntos, lo demás normal, una vez que tengan lo guardan y ahora si les voy a pasar un
link en el cual se van a ingresar, los voy a pasar dos, para que se entiende que lo conocen,
los voy a pasar la mensajería de mit, eso copiense, guardense por si acaso, guardense,
dos links estoy mandando, ya los he enviado uno, los voy a mandar el otro, copiense porque
a veces se pierde o la misma red se actualiza y ya no hay caso de encontrarlo, ya los he enviado,
ya los dos guarden en un blackmail no te esperan que a futuro tampoco lo puedan perder o olvidarse
que tenían que hacer, eso los voy a ayudar bastante, ya, ahí los voy a esperar un ratito de
moratito chicos, de moratito, de moratito, mi disculpa chicos, estoy con un celular que me está
dejando problemas y ahorita estoy viendo eso, listo
listo ahora si, ¿qué deben estar ahí?
no
ahora si chicos, una vez que tengan eso lo guardan y vamos a entrar al primer link que les
he pasado, ya voy a copiarme de nuevo el link que les he enviado, ya voy a copiarlo acá,
listo,
esa es la documentación de evolution API, ahí está todo, ya aquí está todo,
semana extraña porque la mayoría tiene,
está en portugués pero ya que usted está más alabarcelero, saben ahora portugués la mayoría
supongo, entonces voy a hacer lo siguiente, mejor voy a abrir uno más,
ya ahora si, de esa parte, ya, acá como podemos ver acá aquí dice evolution API, hacen clica ahí,
aquí les va a decir cómo conectarse, ya a localhost, a lo demás para que ustedes puedan
conectarse a sus whatsapp y demás, ya, a ver otra forma, ahí lo que es evocerem y evolution,
ahí por algunos, aquí se puede manejar diferentes tipos de usuarios, guías de instalación,
está todo casi, solamente como les voy a repetir, un informático, un ingeniería informático,
leyendo estas cosas no nos aprende, autoidacta, ya, pues no sé si es una escuchación, no se interesa
esto de ingeniería informática porque es más autoidacta, los hackers son autoidactas, así que
si quieren ver hackers lean documentaciones y normal van a poder conectarse,
y entonces vuelven a lo que estábamos es recto, de nuevo ahí al link, y aquí los va a
hacer unos rock 404, no sé por qué está esto acá, pero no estaba suelto, solamente colocan
aquí sentage mesh, y los va a llevar a este lugar, ya, dentro de acá ha cambiado,
hasta no harás eso de interfaz, se pongan los meses, es lo diferente, ya, estos que están viendo
acá los instants, generalmente se utilizan más para cloud API, o sea, si ustedes van a pagar una
suscripción con meta, esto utiliza, igual es la función autoid, pero este por ejemplo,
instants y el chat de acá son netamente para meta, lo que hemos hecho hace dos clases,
hace una clase, van dos clases, no, si quieren que trabaja con la API directa y la API legal de meta,
trabajen con lo que dice acá, pero si vamos a trabajar con evolución API, netamente no sirve
esta parte, generalmente este voy a utilizar sent text mesh, ya, algo click y hasta abierto,
obviamente, ya, ahora a partir de acá voy a empezar a analizar qué es lo que quiero hacer,
esto por ejemplo, aquí si nos damos cuenta en la parte derecha dice sentes mesh, todo esto que
van acá, hay que llevarlo a n8, no solamente en n8, si quieren automatizar con sus propios
rengujes, también se aplica con estos, ya, estos son como les diría las puertas que me abren para
conectarme a otros servicios, esos, aquí también hay 200, 400, fíjense, error 400,
error 400, bueno, esto ya es más en points que nosotros utilizamos, pero nosotros nosotros solamente
200, cuando yo digo 200 o les aparezca en, en alguna página no se sienta visto, error 404,
error 400, error 500, esos casos son quizás no se ha enviado bien, quizás no existen,
tienen varios, varios significados, si los de error 200, también está todo funcionando
kabar porque está entrando y está saliendo mensajes, ya, o lo que queramos, y aquí está todo lo que
tienen que ustedes analizar, ahora a partir de esto voy a verlo en n8, no, no esto ahora me va a meter n8,
voy a cerrar unos ventanas que tengo, listo, ahora si, voy a aclararme una, ya aquí van
a conocerse, whatsapp, whatsapp, whatsapp peter, más en htn, más evolución, evolución,
API, listo, ahora si, para hacer prueba acá me voy a alejar un poquito y voy a empezar a sacar
acá, vamos a elegirnos el one chat message, es para probitos simples, no hay problema,
ya, o también podemos elegirnos, vamos a elegir otro trigger a ver, one chat, one chat
serial war, un web call también, pero ya, mi instante, http, requests, ya, así tiene que
estar, ahora vamos a hacer la prueba, por ejemplo este de acá, si le mando un hola por acá y lo
envío, se va a pintar eso supongo, ya, normal, ya, esto todavía no está ejecutado porque tenemos
que hacer los demás, no hay lío, ya, ahora si, vamos a empezar por acá, vamos a elegir
algunas cositas, nada, se vea, déjame pensar que podemos trabajar, otro one chat, esto lo voy a
borrar mejor para no tener problemas, y vamos a elegir un one chat, pero con algunos características
que voy a manejar, settings y programators, deschatos, testes, al haber un cacho, porque
creo que no está funcionando esta cosa, ya, ya funcionan aquí, ya, antes de unir, hagan
probitos, ya, ahora si, antes de unir, voy a venir acá, ya, generalmente todas las veces que voy a manejar
es con método post, ya, post recolocar, ahora aquí, aquí esta parte del URL, le hay que tener
bastante cuidado, pero que vamos a manejar unos URLs internas que nosotros podamos trabajar, me voy a
ir a mi, les voy a pasar un link de un momentito para que no se nadie tan bien donde está ese link,
ya, creo que es lo siguiente, no me encuentro, de aquí no me sacaremos, ya por ejemplo acá, si nos vamos
acá, aquí dice URL, ¿se dan cuenta? ahí dice HTTP, todo esto me voy a copiar, todo esto,
todo eso me copio hasta ahí, sin el URL, ya, contuse y vámonos a nuestro N8, ya, acá van a colocar eso,
pero esta parte que están manejando acá, el localhost, lo van a eliminar, o le van a colocar
directamente, ¿por qué puede que estábamos escuchando? ojo, esta parte si se dan cuenta, vamos
trabajando con Docker, ¿no? y Docker, dentro de Docker me está dando un localhost, ya, eso es lo que
cual era, el 777, ¿no? te se van a colocar, y aquí donde dice InstaName, lo van a borrar y van a venir
acá a su Evolution API, van a entrar su Evolution Manager, van a hacer su dashboard y van a copiarse
este nombrecito, esa es su instancia de ustedes, voy a hacer copia en eso y lo van a pegar acá,
ya está, una vez que lo colocan ahí, voy a empezar a venir y voy a habilitar estos send headers,
listo, y aquí vamos a notar algunos puntos, ya, nombre y demás, este caso me dice headers, ya,
cuando me habla de mí de header, voy a tratar de implementar esos valorcitos que tengo por
cabezales, ahora si nos vamos acá, voy a mirarme otro de estos, ahí está,
ya aquí está, header content type, esta parte si te voy a copiar,
y le voy a pegar ahí, ya, acá lo voy a pegar, voy a añadirme otro porque hay dos headers,
voy a volver acá, de que el otro dice apiqui, lo copio y lo vuelvo a pegar acá,
ya, hasta ahí, espero que me estén siguiendo, una vez que vayan haciendo esa parte, ya puedo
empezar a trabajar con un apiquis y los content type, ya, en este caso el content type van a
tratar de manera como lo había manejado, ya, me lo titulo, voy a pasar esta parte, es bastante código,
ya, acá por ejemplo, voy a volver acá, van a colocar esto, se copian del primer header,
y esta parte necesitamos un valor de la apiqui, esa apiqui lo van a sacar de su revolution API,
voy a llevar mi revolution API, y aquí dicen, aquí los da un aquí, lo pueden copiar,
y una vez que lo copien, lo van a pegar acá, ya, hasta ahí, una vez que hagan eso, van a enviarse
en somebody, esto pueden colocarlo en formato JSON o en formato data, pero en este caso voy a trabajar
con números, ya, si trabajamos en formato JSON, voy a colocar aquí, creo que quiero,
qué parámetros quiero enviar, o a quién quiero enviar, ya, voy a colocar number, ya, ahora dónde
van a sacar esto, igual está acá, igual está acá, ven, number, el otro me dice texto,
ah ya, voy a benautarme lo otro entonces, pero fíjense aquí me dice, escribí algo y aquí me
dice escribí algo, por si tienen estas, estos símbolos de más y menos, pero qué es, eso significa
que tengo que anotar ahí algo, pero qué no sé, eso me dice, ya, nos vengo acá, vuelvo acá y voy
a colocar test texto, ya, aquí text, en el número tienen que enviar, a quién le van a enviar el dato,
ahorita os voy a anotar los test, pero ahorita voy a hacer prueba con mi otro número, 591,
y uno, qué era esto, yo se lo he hecho, se los he hecho, listo, y aquí voy a colocar el valor,
pues si, hola, hola, cómo estás, listo, y con eso pues ya está, podemos ejecutarlo,
ya, pero voy a cerrar un poco ahí, ya voy a conectar el chat, ya, ahora si podemos ejecutar,
si hacemos click, está pensando un poco, ya me he enviado, y justamente no se ha escuchado,
ahorita los voy a mostrar mis servos, que estoy con whatsapp, whatsapp, ahorita,
ya, los voy a mostrar, pequeñito ya, de verdad,
por ejemplo, aquí estoy, ya me he enviado, los voy a enviar este porcito, ven aquí,
ya me dice, qubit, hola, cómo estás, ya, listo, y ya está, ya me he enviado, haciendo esto chicos,
ya pueden hacer todo, absolutamente todo, aquí añado, y ya se ha añadido,
a ver, voy a enviarle a otro, ya, a ver, voy a pedir que me envíen ustedes sus números,
vamos a hacer pruebas, y me van a enviar pruebas a mí luego, ya, a ver, debo un número, a ver,
voy a llamar a alguien, ya, alguien me puede a su número, a ver, que me de alguien su número,
puedes que viva en el chat, su número telefónico, su celular, para que yo le enví,
acá, listo, gracias, Sandra, a ver, vamos a enviar a la Sandra, a ver si le llega a mi empresa,
ya lo mismo, ejecutamos, ya le debió enviar, ya debes recibir Sandra,
gracias, gracias, gracias Sandra, y así, entonces, en base a eso,
podría trabajar ustedes, aquí ya pueden implementar opiniones y demás, eso,
has visto que es mucho más fácil que, que la pide meta, y ahora sí, haremos
partecita de ese proyecto, los voy a dar esa tarea, y vamos a terminar la clase,
ustedes nos diezmienes más, ya, no sé qué, aguanten chicos, ahora sí, vamos a abrir
la opinion y ya podemos abrir las bases de datos, etcétera, un montón de cosas, ya con esto,
ya, lo siguiente clase, vamos a hacer ya la parte de citas, imágenes, videos, estructural,
que nuestra propia página ya envía automáticamente, etcétera, y vamos a tratar de comprimirlo,
ahora qué es lo que se hace en un principio, cuando llegamos a ese punto, ustedes, si es que
no quieren comprar ningún plan, qué van a hacer cada mañana, o sea, lamentablemente,
así cada mañana, no sé qué tengan un un computador que trabaje 24-7, hay, las
descriptorios pueden trabajar, prenden en la mañana, si llegamos a un trabajo con su laptop,
no es recomendable, porque los laptops se descalan y demás, yo les recomiendo una
computadora escritoria con una buena capacidad de no que ni ni siquiera si necesitan capacidad,
no sé qué prendo todo el día y listo, ya, le colocan, habilitan su docker, habilitan su
nhn, sin entrar acá, ahora les voy a enseñar luego a finales de la clase, cómo es eso, del curso,
y automáticamente ustedes reciben recepción de mensajes y automáticos, imagínense, puedo hacer
lo siguiente, voy a hacer esto, a penía, pero vamos a hacer acá, a penía, vamos a irnos a
la clistofa, la recepción model,
yo voy a añadirme, esto vamos a añadirlo así, esto voy a eliminarlo, en vez de esto voy a
eliminar esto, voy a eliminar esta cosa, vamos a metería webhooks, ya, delete,
ahora un webhook, webhook listo, ya saben todo, todo esto ya lo saben, ya, un webhook, luego si quieren
capturar pantalla son edit fills, edit fills y listo, ya lo tienen acá,
ya está, luego le generan su modelo, ahora vamos a añadir una secuela, si bueno,
voy a tener una base data interna, perdón, voy a tratar, mysql, listo, ya está,
eso, incluso luego pueden añadir acá otro que es un HTTP request tool, listo, ahora vamos a
eliminarlo más, luego una base data mysql o sql,
insert rows select rows from table, pueden utilizar eso,
ya, perdón, yo me estoy equivocando, de aquí tenía que ser clicado, ahora sí, perdón,
ya aquí van a colocar un sql, luego lo repartir, listo, ahora aquí, aquí pueden
utilizar la primera opción que sería select, por select, porque esta base data me puedes
ver para que yo entregué datos del empresa, es decir horarios de atención, quizás fotografías,
quizás PDF, aquí ya se va a guardar, ahí van esas datos, eso es para select seleccional y que se
envíen ahí, luego otro el mismo van a utilizar sql, perdón cada vez me olvido esta parte, sql,
pero en este caso ustedes van a trabajar con insert, es decir, van a recibir los datos,
van a agrupar los datos del cliente que se está enviando, para luego molestarlo, no se
han visto, cuando nos enviamos para un diplomado, para un curso, cada vez les molesta, no les llaman,
es por eso, algunos tienen interfaces internas que les detectan y con eso automáticos les envían,
les hacen llamadas, etcétera, luego tienen que tener otro sql, ahora sí, tienen que tener otro
sql, pero en este caso netamente de la siguiente la cerística, tiene que, en este caso, insertar o
actualizar, ya por qué, generalmente qué pasa con este tipo de base de datos, paso lo siguiente,
esta base de datos me puede servir uno, no sé si se han dado cuenta, en algunos grupos de WhatsApp,
no sé si se han dado cuenta que hay bastantes números que se actualicen, o sea, dicen tal
número, cambio a tal número, y de la nada te vuelve a llamar la empresa que quizás no estaba
registrado en el nuevo, pero te llama, raro, no es como si estuvieran haciendo spies, es por esta cosa,
le detecta, lo actualiza y lo vuelve a guardar su nuevo número, es como si esto lo hubiera
siguiendo la corriente, luego le pueden insertar, si es que no quieren trabajar con eso, Excel,
ya pueden trabajar con mcps, aquí con webx pueden trabajar, pero luego vamos a ver,
como webx, pero aquí está, Microsoft Excel, ya pueden armarse esos sistemas acá, con eso,
Sofi, luego aparte de eso, no solamente quiero que a mí me envíe digamos, un HTTP requests,
obviamente esto me va a enviar, no vea mi número, así va a estar, pero aparte yo quiero quizás
que me envíe también ese mismo dato a mi correo, así que ya saben hacer eso,
así que el gmail normal lo jalan, y vamos a hacer un message, listo, ya está, con eso entonces ya
tendrían más o menos tu eliminar un parámetro de cómo lo puedes sintetizar, pero ya saben que
tengo que venir, no vea, y entonces voy a unir algunos puntos con cores o demás, para esto vamos a
hacer las acciones en mapa, vamos a utilizar, a ver qué podemos utilizar con esto, Angoli es bueno,
a los intres vamos a ver algo de Angoli, ya, ya sana, ya, entonces esto ya la pueden generar,
ahí, ahí mientras tanto, ya, pero si se dan cuenta, podemos incrementar nuestro flujo bastante,
ya, entonces a partir de, y este wef ya tiene que estar escuchando, escuchando a partir de qué
tipo de URL le va a admitir, y en base a esto vamos a hacer lo siguiente, ya de un rato les voy a
pasar el youtube code, haremos un agente bastante interesante, pero antes de empezar esto,
voy a hacer esta cierta partida, la siguiente vamos a continuar, voy a clonar esto, ya, vamos a clonar
para hacer otros pruebas, vieron a tres puntos, lo duplican,
y van a colocar acá más agendas, ya, lo duplican y listo, ya ha creado otro workflow,
que va a tener los mismos, aquí lo voy a borrar todo esto, porque quiero que se mantenga lo que
estaba, ya, igual control Z pueden apretar para,
para que se mantenga como era el principio, listo, ahí me interesa, esto lo voy a eliminar,
esto lo elimino, listo, eso va a ser mi whatsapp viene a join, ya, ahora lo voy a hacer ahora
esto, ahora aquí trabajaremos un otro, ahora también podemos trabajar con algunos agentes,
ahora voy a trabajar con agentes, ya, ya no voy a trabajar con mensajes o modelos,
así que esta parte lo voy a eliminar, acá sí la mayoría, ya empezaremos con algunos
puntos, ya, de primero esta parte se nos voy a eliminar, vieron acá y van a colocar ahí agents,
ahí está,
vamos a enliquir, listo, si se dan cuenta, aquí es donde ya, ya empezamos a hacer que son agentes de
día, ya, aquí como se los vea, ya he comentado en un inicio del curso, ya no se trabaja solamente
con una inteligencia artificial, yo los recomiendo que trabajen con un modelo nomás, es que su negocio
no es tan complejo, ¿cómo pueden diferenciar ese modelo complejo? Por ejemplo, si yo quiero no
solamente hacer marketing, o sea responder, recibir y así, sosivamente mi flujo de datos,
ustedes también pueden implementar tres modelos, ya saben, uno es Gemini, que con nano banana hace
un montón de imágenes, ya, eso es justamente para la partida de imágenes, si ustedes quieren enviar a
sus clientes o quieren mostrar cosas realistas o que hace interesantes, puede mandarle algo, pero no
lo veo mucho en negocio de eso, desde mi punto de vista. Ponto dos, OpenEye, OpenEye me sirve más para
responder de manera adecuada y de manera robusta, se podría decir, ¿cuál tipo de mensajes? OpenEye,
o sea, Chachapiti, ya lo esperamos. Gemini es más para redacción de artículos y también para la
parte de ordenamiento, no sé, parece que me sirve Gemini. DeepSick es para programación junto
con Cloud, son los dos potentes en programación, ¿ya? DeepSick, lo malo de DeepSick es que no tiene
mucha actualización, pero tiene buen nivel de código igual que Cloud. Cloud ya puede utilizar
la automatización más avanzada, pero yo lo recomiendo esos cuatro. Si quieren utilizar otros,
más se puede, pero saben que es los más de mercados, hacen clic acá, ya que hay un montón de
modelos que ustedes pueden utilizar y el único que son que utilizan es OpenEye, Chachemoder,
ya, ahora ya no lo estamos utilizando como respuesta directa, lo estamos utilizando como agente.
Vamos a utilizar uno más. Ah, pero voy a venir acá, voy a escribir en este caso.
Utilizamos a DeepSick también, ya DeepSick.
Ahora, vamos a utilizar uno específico para no tener problemas.
DeepSick, Chachemoder.
Listo, voy a utilizar dos agentes, por ejemplo, ya. Ahora van a ver acá, listo.
Aquí ya podemos, se llaman autofijaciones, van a ver acá, no quiere conectarse, no es porque me
está diciendo esto. De aquí vamos a utilizar MultiQueries Retribuers, ya, eso lo clic y aquí
podemos utilizar un montón de modelos que se pueden multiplicar y esto se conecta directamente
con este, pero todavía no lo voy a utilizar, lo vamos a utilizar en la última clase que
los demás agentes ya. En memoria ya pueden utilizar bases de datos, o sea, dónde quieren que el guarde.
Una simple memoria de NLN, el notic que dice que no necesita credenciales, o sea, me conviene,
lo puedo guardar ahí mientras tanto. Listo, voy a dejar un poquito para que no se...
Y en herramientas, les va a parecer igual a opciones, qué opciones tienen, HTTP,
mcps, hay vector stores, por ejemplo estos vector stores trabajan igual con algunos
tipos de bases de datos en la nube, ya, y obviamente todos son de paga en la mayoría,
su pavés hemos visto que no es de paga, pueden utilizar eso, pero no necesito más,
sí puede ser, pero Redis puede ser también, pero no me lo se paga, solo mantiene un usuario,
si quiero recomiendo algo locado, ya, eso lo conectan acá y lo conectan acá directamente,
ya, nada más. Y esta parte ya sabe, no, Openian ChatModel, bien, acá, ya está, no sé si lo
puedo borrar de esa cuenta, no me cura, ya, y eso, y aquí empieza con un juego de Fog
y van a lanzar una página, tarea para siguiente semana,
ya tendrán de hacer funcionar esto, y eso va a ser su última práctica, estitunos,
ya saben esta parte, ya saben todo esto, esta memoria quizás no, no los voy a exigir esto,
esto eliminan lo, pero yo voy a hacer con ustedes, pero esto quiero que corra para ustedes, ya saben
cómo hacer webhooks, ya saben cómo adquirir la URL para que se, desde su, de lo que hemos creado,
no ver, internamente nuestro propio código, desde ahí tiene que enviarse y les tiene que responder,
porque aquí ya está codificado, o sea, ya está configurado el HTTP, que es para la parte del
evolution API, así que no hay lío de esto, solamente tendrán que trabajar,
con su modelo que igual os voy a pasar de nuevo el token, y esto ya saben, contar que les responda y
que le digan, digamos, envíame al ChatModel, tendría que decir, envíame de manera adecuada,
de manera concisa, con viñetas para enviar un mensaje de texto en base a mi empresa,
tal cual tal cosa es mi empresa, y cuando ustedes los reciban en su whatsapp,
eso sí va bien ordenado, con viñetas, con emoticones, con todo eso, ya, ese es su tarea,
chicos, así que si se pueden ahorita, saquen lo scream, para no estar viendo el vídeo de
nuevos, si quieren verlo, y así que, eso es su tarea, listo, esa es la clase de hoy,
voy a llamarles lista, de ahí vamos a terminar, ya, andame un cachito, pero voy a sacar sus
existencias de hoy día, de un rato de, perdón, los de Pantaria. Hagan la prueba, vuelvas a
patrines con business, no les recomiendo mucho con sus propios números, si quieren hacer artus,
si quieren trabajar con bastante flujo, no les recomiendo que hagan con sus números reales
oficiales, ya, si nos van a querer luego, natar a mi, ya, de un cachito, voy a sacar tres screams,
vale, embajada, más me dice que lo envíe, listo, ya, el jueves sería nuestra penúltima clase,
y el sábado estaríamos terminando totalmente las clases, ya, ya empezaríamos desde el sub
siguiente jueves con la parte de sus defensas, ya, supongo que hasta el sábado vamos a ya
tener casi todo, así que los que son primeros en la lista, traten chicos de volar, porque
cuidado, pero es piso el tiempo, yo voy a tratar de terminar lo más antes posible, para hacer
solamente pruebas al último clase, así tengan más tiempo de hacer ya sus cosas, ya, ahora se
voy a dejar de compartir y voy a dejar de grabar, te voy a llamar lista, ya, y tener grabación